so you're a scholar of history including
hip-hop history
you've uh i've listened to so many of
your interviews uh you've spoken
brilliantly about
some of the big figures in
in hip-hop history tupac biggie nas many
others
maybe uh let's look at tupac and biggie
what made them special in the history of
music
that's a good question
so i don't know if i'm the authority to
answer it
but i'll just speak my
piece on it and maybe i can just add on
because i'm sure it's a lot of people
that spend a lot of time with them
that could speak on it but just as a
fellow artist
um i think
not only was big or dope lyricists
i think he had a voice
that was really immaculate
in the sense that
some rappers
get on top of music
and you gotta get used to them or you
gotta fight you know you gotta vibe with
them
but he
make a record sounds like a record
immediately
if you go back and listen
to his music you could take his voice
and put it on anything and for some
reason
it sounds like a record
you know i mean you mean just like the
raw voice of the man yeah you could just
listen to raw and it sounds like a
record yeah but if you put a beat take
his voice and put it on any beat
it's he just has a voice
it's immaculate you know
so his lyrical skills and all that was
great
um and you got to think once again
he's doing all this he's not even 25
years old yeah yeah
you